[Music]
in oskar war news submitted by 80s baby
the Department of Justice has warned the
Oscars not to block Netflix from
competing for awards for dude so Halle
was trying to try to stop Netflix from
competing in the awards categories oh I
understand what what she said I
understand what Steve said yeah cuz I
said it as a man only Smashbox so that's
how you know what I'm saying is real
okay it's for this for the white person
in my life I saw Netflix Ovie's cannot
qualify for Oscars and the Oscars are
trying to push those new rules saying
like oh you know you can't have any
films that had like a brief stint in
theaters to participate in because I'm
trying to get an award because that's
what Netflix did this last year where
they held Roma in theaters for like
three weeks to qualify - oh they're
trying to running and actually won also
they have to be in tears for a long time
that's what Steven Spielberg is trying
to push so he doesn't walk he's pushing
this he's pushing this he's against
streaming like crazy so just he's saying
that it's that they should only have
movies or films that have been in
theaters they're afraid it's gonna kill
the model where it's like yeah movie
comes out in thousands of screens and
then movie goes to streaming service
like they're very scared about all that
getting sucked away by Netflix yeah what
Netflix is already kind of doing yeah
and Romo came close to winning the Oscar
so now they're really trying to be like
yo this cannot happen again lots of
stuff but they didn't win best picture
which is what they were up for but yeah
so the Department of Justice said that
that may raise some antitrust concerns
and they're saying like pretty much you
can't do that because there needs to be
like a fair competition and by you
having these rules
that's not meanwhile [ __ ] Fox gets
bought by goddamn Disney it's like
there's no antitrust for that [ __ ] are
you kidding me everything's rigged dude
it's what Disney ABC is now same as Mars
doors they [ __ ] have the x-men now
back and they have all this other [ __ ]
and it's like easy
oh but antitrust for this other [ __ ] I'm
like bro words antitrust for all this
other stuff
might as well just buy Apple at this
point - exactly antitrust my ass dude we
don't have any trust anymore and we
should like all these big-ass companies
like the Google buying up all these
places and it's like wait you're only
gonna have one place yeah for
information processing all this [ __ ] I
don't like that I thought you're not I
thought that goes under like monopoly
rule - like you can't be the one because
then you control the whole market space
yourself what happened to that ID yeah
we used to have people out there saying
like we gotta have no monopolies [ __ ]
this [ __ ] now those people are all
bought and paid for gone they're all
gone I can't remember I'm not sure don't
quote me on this but when I when I
wasn't busy econ I remember we were
learning about how Microsoft actually
helped Apple out because if they didn't
they would have been considered a
monopoly so they funded that [ __ ] was
going down and they rebuilt it up so it
would be fair you know good actually
they got sued at the time yeah okay yeah
that's so [ __ ] crazy then what the
[ __ ] exactly yeah it makes you wonder
yeah
so Steven Spielberg is like completely
against any type of so does he want
there to want
he wants there to be like another
category for screaming films is that
what he wants he thinks that streaming
platforms should be winning Emmys not
Oscars that's like a lot of directors
like that I think
Nolan's on board with that I didn't
Tarantino doesn't even want to shoot on
digital at all he thinks everything she
even just be on film for that [ __ ]
afford to be that cocky dude I think a
lot of the old-school guys like like you
said they want to keep the model going
I mean I guess I kind of understand it
but it's not gonna happen this is what
happens all the time though right it's
like when the internet was coming out or
like even when uber came out and all the
taxi drivers unions are all like hey no
way [ __ ] uber we got to make it illegal
and everyone's like yeah sure dude and
then everyone was using uber at the same
time you know they came over but they
have succeeded that in other countries
around the world where birds banned like
right and yeah I'm sure the locals love
that because the taxi guys get a
monopoly on and that's what's happening
right now - with with uber and lyft like
all the drivers are pissed because the
rates are so low now and now they want
to raise the rates up and so they'll be
like back where the taxi cabs you guys
read there's a new one coming out a new
right ways has it two ways right sure
wait has carpool ride-sharing so you
could carpool on ways now they have they
have a carpool I've seen everybody know
it was yeah I would I don't know like oh
this is so weird - because you know just
talking about that type of [ __ ] - I
always thought that it was like the
taxis father so you should have evolved
I should coming a mile away yeah yeah
you know cuz it was so terrible to use a
taxi if you remember like using a taxi
you just felt like it felt ropes all the
time yeah it felt seedy if all your
getting ripped off half the time you
were it felt like the yellow police car
yeah sixty bucks just to get your [ __ ]
hotel yeah the [ __ ] I'm gonna be ejected
by a taxi driver once he was like no not
far enough and they just take me to my
hotel no but I'd like yeah like you're
actually if by law Texas driver cannot
refuse to pick up someone oh so he was
just like no not far enough and you just
booked get the [ __ ] dude I'm like why am
i paying for the ship go back then in
taxi days I'm like it smells like
boogers in here one thing that is cool
is they actually helping with the bags
though if you get off from the airport
they'll help you open it for you enough
for me we've been with you dude any part
of the time in an uber now the thing
that pisses me off is like the guys
always like hey is the music okay
is air ok is the [ __ ] everything okay
I said it was fine
five minutes ago five stars I know
exactly you guys see in the [ __ ] uber
vending machines no so I just got into
BRR last week and this dude had a
vending machine of Shaq's chocolate
chips whatever and you can like put in a
quarter and it's just honest is armrest
space in the backseat oh that's lovely
yeah if you get some of the ubers just
have it there for free though yeah yeah
but there was like I tried and gone my
name Brad [ __ ]
no anyway lies too like I I think as I
started to write more ubers I just don't
want them to talk to me at all yeah I
don't want them to feel like they have
to in the app it's awkward it's like
talk to me or I don't mind or let me
sleep or don't talk to me I'd always
have no there was a photo of this uber
driver he has a menu that you can choose
from I know I was actually really done
menu like a do you want a funny ride of
rifle facts you want me to be a quiet
right or do you want me to be the rudest
ride ever I'll insult you the whole way
through port oh no it was a picture of
it and I'm like yeah and then like he'll
just like give a brief description of
each one and then the last ones like I
will I will I will break through the
whole entire way and try to make you cry
okay yeah at least you have [ __ ]
options that would be yeah because I
don't mind if they're just quiet if we
just go all the way through and I wake
up at my spot I like guys never sleeping
over but if anybody rapes me you've
earned it no joke this young guy was
driving week me and Nicky get in he's
like a little disco ball and he's like
you guys want the disco ball and
everything and I was like Nicky we have
to do we have to say it whatever he's
gonna do right now is gonna be so funny
we have to say it so he puts on the
disco ball the lights are going and [ __ ]
and he's like what are you doing tonight
and I'm like trying to get [ __ ] but
he's like how yeah I think he liked
cranks on like shitty to do that music
and now I'm like I just met this [ __ ] I
think it's going good this is what this
is how the guy sees America I'm like I'm
gonna give him the experience
I saw over Cartier so you called the the
cupid I saw it too it's like love
everywhere yeah yeah it's like a giant
sign on this rooftop this is love and
there's like science arts and [ __ ] yeah
it was charged on Main Street
yeah all right that means Jessa on there
free we going to the office around here
uber used to have like good quality
control for the types of cars you get
picked up on I don't think that happens
anymore I've been getting some shitty
cast cars here a lot of stains a lot of
old cars smells bad so either that
either that or they're registering that
type of car but they're using their
other car for it or so or something
that's going on happen to the giant lift
mustaches those are cute
well they just have like the globe yeah
I like the glow light cuz when you go in
oh really I like when you get in and
then you're like hey it's kind of hot in
here getting on the air and then he
turns it on to one and I'm like you
mother [ __ ] I can feel I like the uber
drivers that are so cheap you don't want
to turn on the AC so these roll down the
window on the freeway have you had that
[ __ ] dude they were just well we need
the windows down in parents cuz the Bo
was wild dude it was almost like I was
being assaulted yeah yeah me too I got
out of his taxi and [ __ ] threw up
back from the palace of versaille he
came back and then like rushed out of
the cab into a bush and just threw up
cuz he the dude smelled so bad dude
that's like Van Nuys is basically like
Paris cuz every grocery store I go to oh
my god bo everybody has Bo everybody you
sell deodorant here
yeah I'll take you all I'll show you
where it is I was reading up some [ __ ]
article about Korean people and not
having you know cuz we had that
conversation about jalapeno vo and know
what your wax
yes you do [ __ ] yeah so I've never had
Bo growing up and I possible you're a
fat kid do I know so I have like sweat
like this is way near the fat boy job
it's our sweet the Bo thing so I didn't
know what that was I just thought that's
what American people smell like it's all
just like oh is this what American
people smell like European Bo common in
Asian some agents how you can tell so
there's a like knife something for some
Asians don't need the owner inks they
don't produce odors and and also very
and
earwax is dry it's white and flaky is
yours white and flaky yeah so if you
have like what yellow like thick earwax
then that means you produce like
underarms like body odor yes in general
and they have to use deodorant and I
didn't know this until I dated a Korean
he said yeah I've never had C and I'm
like what are you talking about my knee
would work out I'm like this guy any one
person the Asian people like age now
it's really common sorry do you have BL
and I have it what earwax - but you do
you have like white flaky I have no Bo
and like I'll I think I've had it before
but I was like it was like church
volleyball is outside for eight hours
oh yeah there's something developed but
it took a long time we're wet your
wife's and I don't give you really do
you see what you also don't move at all
movement requires that too a little bit
it's probably - yeah I don't
yeah but I do I still put you order an
ounce I'm like this is what normal
people do yeah so yeah when I was [ __ ]
not like a sociopath dude I shall brush
my teeth tips like cooking her something
to me and she's like what's my best
human improve the humans enjoyed this I
shall enjoy this as well there's like
certain Asian girls that don't even
brilliant trying to be human the time
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]